أوكرانيا بحجم ولاية تكساس فقط ،
فلماذا تحتاج روسيا إلى الكثير من القوة
لملاحقة هذه المنطقة الصغيرة هنا
لماذا ملأوا المنطقة
بالعديد من الخبراء العسكريين المختلفين
الذين نظروا في هذا الأمر ، يقولون إنهم
يعتقدون أنه لأنهم يريدون  للحصول على
قوة ساحقة
لدعم مهمة حفظ السلام هذه
هنا وربما لنقلها إلى أبعد من ذلك ،
ما نوع القوة التي نتحدث عنها عن
أشياء مثل قاذفة القنابل ذات الظهر الكامل القادرة
على إطلاق صواريخ خارقة للتحصينات
من عبر الحدود دون حتى
الدخول إلى المجال الجوي الأوكراني  أشياء
مثل نظام الصواريخ الباليستية قصيرة المدى iscander m
هناك 36 من
هذه الصواريخ خارج الحدود وفقًا
لنطاق أوكرانيا 310 ميل أي ما يقرب من
نصف المسافة عبر البلاد
مرة أخرى دون حتى عبور الحدود
إذا كانوا يريدون ذلك ، ثم بالطبع
سيفعلون ذلك.  لديهم الدبابات التي
يرسلونها عادة مع قواتهم
بمدفعيتهم في كل مكان
وبعد ذلك قد يكون لديهم حتى  لقد
لعب أسطول البحر الأسود دورًا نشطًا للغاية هنا
، ثم القوات الأخرى التي
تتحرك من هذه المنطقة في النهاية ، فإن
أحد المخاوف التي
لدى الاستراتيجيين العسكريين للغرب هو أنهم إذا
انتقلوا إلى هذه المنطقة ، فإن روسيا لن
تقول  مجرد أننا نضع
قوات حفظ سلام هنا
ولكنهم قد يقولون دعونا
ننشئ جسرًا بريًا إلى شبه جزيرة القرم وهو ما نريده على
أي حال وبسبب الخطر لماذا
لا توجد منطقة
أبعد قليلاً هنا فقط لنقول إننا "  إعادة فقط
فصل الجميع عن بعضهم البعض حتى لا يكون
هناك الكثير من القتال ومن ثم ربما بعد
ذلك القلق هو ماذا لو قالوا
إننا سنبذل قصارى جهدنا للخروج هنا إلى
نهر القراص ونقول كل
هذا لروسيا وبواسطة
إذا كان الجيش الأوكراني هنا يقاوم
هذا ، فهناك خوف حقيقي من أن ما
قد تحاول روسيا فعله هو التمسك
خلفهم وعزلهم بشكل أساسي
والتوصل إلى ما
تبقى من أوكرانيا
متناقصة للغاية وخريطة مختلفة تمامًا